hi I'm Jess executive producer on League
of Legends and hi I'm Andre and I'm the
game director on League of Legends and
this is League of Legends
[Music]
support at Jerry Ferrara I am determined
to get decent at League of Legends
currently I am getting my ass kicked in
response mind of ab I have tried
watching it on Twitch and don't get it
is it better to play to get a better
feel for the game I know it is crazy
popular just don't understand some of it
Basics here League of Legends is a team
based game two teams competing over
about 30 35 minutes to try and destroy
the other team's base everybody picks a
unique character there's a really large
roster you pick from it's a pretty deep
game it can be pretty hard to get into
and I think the way we've seen people
have the most success with that is to
play with a friend or somebody who
already knows some of the game have
somebody teach you the ropes and get you
past that initial learning stage for a
lot of people it also works well just
dive straight in I would definitely try
to pick a champion that you think you
can can stick with for a few games a
character that you really like if you
like their theme that helps a lot and
just stick with it honestly like as long
as you kind of understand the basics of
try to get the Nexus you'll learn a lot
of the mechanics along the way getting
good at League of Legends that's such a
hard question depending on what your
definition of good is it's kind of like
asking how how how do you get good how
long does it take to get good at a sport
like you might start doing well compared
to other new players almost immediately
and then we've got people who are
insistent that even people have played
thousands of games even some of the
people who play professionally are not
good enough for their standards of good
at gz QJ Lov V2 e0 wg1 W asks at League
of Legends will you develop a mobile
game for League of legs that's a great
question and the answer is yes uh we are
currently working on this right now and
we actually announced it during our
League of Legends 10 year anniversary
it's called wild Rift uh hopefully it's
going to come out soon and we hope you
like it at cor Barry asks what's some
fun facts about League of Legends well
one fun fact we just had the 10th
anniversary for League of Legends last
year and as part of that we're sort of
reflecting and looking back at just how
much the game both has and hasn't
changed over the years it's core is
still very much the same game that
launched back in you know 2009 but
almost every element of it has has been
refined has evolved over time and we
occasionally get the question you know
when are you going to make League of
Legends 2 and I think from our
perspective we've made League of Legends
2 probably League of Legends 3 and four
already at this point but our style is
just to keep those things rolling out as
a constant series of updates to the game
rather than a discreet name change and a
a relaunch or anything like that a big
part of League of Legends 10 year
anniversary was announcing a bunch of
games that needed to keep under wraps
for so long us being able to finally
announce all of that and uh and like be
able to have that payoff of no we
actually do want to invest in league
league in the long term as like like as
an ecosystem as a franchise we have like
this lifelong commitment to to the game
and and the sport we're in this for the
Long Haul we won't always get it right
first but we'll keep coming back to it
and figure things out at Neon Cats asks
I'm wondering if there's any wild
Champions reworks or item ideas that
never went through and we never heard of
both kit wise and lur wise I'd like to
hear the most chaotic of ideas please I
live for these Okay so we've tried a lot
of stuff that never ended up happening
for one reason or another I think we'll
focus on the kit side of things rather
than the law side here cuz we're much
more likely to go back to the law side
and don't want to spoil that if we do EO
for example used to have an ultimate
that would rewind the entire game 5 to
10 seconds The Only Exception was if a
champion was dead they'd stay dead but
every other champion and unit on the map
would go back to their previous position
have their health their Mana their cool
Downs reset and so on it created some
really cool and funny moments but a lot
of the time it was just a really
annoying nullification of consequences
and and actions another champion we're
developing at the same time as eeko
was Bard and Bard at one point had an
ultimate that sent out a giant Soundwave
from his team's Nexus that would silence
and slow enemy Champions when they were
in it and the combination of trying to
play test those two at once was just a
bit of a nightmare of endless sound and
slowing waves covering the landscape and
then being reset and repeating over and
over again for some others we had an
idea for a painter champion who had
different colors of Paintbrush and could
make shapes on the ground and then
activate that paint to do things like
you know create sort of fire lines and
you know deal damage or slow or create
walls or whatever based off the shapes
created but it never quite worked out
cuz the best play was usually just
create a blob of paint really quickly
and then just stun stuff in it or
something similar so it sounded all
creative and artistic and it just boiled
down to throw an AOE at them
unfortunately another concept that was
fun but never went anywhere was for a
giant Mech sort of sort of character a
fair bit like Urgot two of his abilities
were shoot left and shoot right he was
like a old school sailing ship and he
had cannons that could only fire out one
side of his body and that was really
novel but it didn't turn out to be that
much fun character got re rebooted this
time with the name shrink and squash
with a bunch of tank trades and the
ability to just run over people and and
squash them and a shrink R to make it
easier to do so again didn't happen uh
what about you GS any anything come to
mind yeah I think of things that are
like yeah a little bit older like when
Ari when she had her old r where you
could basically R from one blue buff to
the other and get both that was
definitely pretty broken there was also
a point where when we were working on uh
scarner we were trying to figure out
what this Crystal scorpion was going to
be and there were like 500 different
versions of this freaking scorpion
ranging from like the Scorpion by itself
to like having like a scorpion riter to
like you know ziggs who I think like
started off as like a potion human like
a an alchemist an alchemist of some sort
there was the kie rework that at one
point had a skill that allowed her to
attach herself to a missile and then
ride along with it so like if your team
had an ash with her Global ultimate AI
could just hop ride on that and travel
across the entire map it was pretty B
buggy pretty janky very powerful it was
cool but it was it was it was not as
useful as you'd think oh aant soul in a
much earlier version had a global lein Q
as his ultimate so he'd fire it out
across the map and if he hit somebody
could then basically Zoom to them
traveling across the entire map at
really high speeds most of the time it
just missed and it was a giant bait for
his team because he'd you know be trying
to split push or whatever and then miss
a skill shot at Leon J Fernandez asks at
League of Legends hello I'm a student
studying games development and a huge
fan of your game any advice on getting
into the game industry I think there's a
lot of ways you can get into the game
industry really depends on kind of what
you want to do if it's art you know
there's a huge swath of of areas within
art right it can be anything from
concept art to 3D modeling to animation
to illustration right to visual design
there's so many types of ways of kind of
deepening your craft and figuring out
okay well if I go into UI like there's
you know I'm looking at menus I'm
looking at progression systems I'm
looking at all sorts of stuff and design
same thing do you want to go into
systems do you want to go into game
mechanics anything is kind of it's your
oyster really understanding uh what
speaks to you and and how you want to
really deepen your craft going hard into
that one one uh line of expertise can
just open up opportunities later for you
to kind of expand and and be able to
make more parts of the game the other
thing I'd suggest doing is just start
making games if you're not already doing
so anything as simple as you know like a
2d shooter or you know like a small
platformer board games using pen and
paper or a homemade RPG campaign if you
kind of use your expertise to maybe add
one differentiator to that game and kind
of talk through what you were trying to
improve with that game it'll both give
you valuable experience and skills and
it gives you great things to put on a
resume or to talk about in an interview
to actually get into the industry that
can be a really great kind of uh insight
into your thought process and and kind
of how you develop games and and that's
actually great to learn from you the
difference between two candidates one of
whom has gone out of their way to to try
and make stuff already who's shown that
passion and learning versus another who
is really interested in it but hasn't
actually put the time and the effort in
yet is really Stark when you're
interviewing somebody Mickey box asks
League of Legends friends any tips on
how to learn a basic build strategy for
two to three Champions Morana Ash Garen
for now so there's a a few different
ways you can approach these um the first
is just jumping into the game starting
with things like the recommended items
experimenting learning what works for
you the second is to go to a lot of the
really good third party sites out there
and they use the League of Legends
API and show off a bunch of of
recommended builds you know things that
do really well for champions in
different contexts like what's good for
morg or Ash and plat plus play for
example and they'll recommend
combinations of of items of Runes of
skill orders those sorts of things and
the third option that could be worth
thinking about is trying to track down
one of the communities for those
Champions things like the Morgana Mains
subreddit subreddit or whatever where
you'll get a lot of talk in detail about
just that particular champion in this
preseason we're also looking into re
ding in the item system and the item
shop so actually this will be a problem
where we're trying to make it a little
bit easier and that'll include things
like recommended items that are
automatically updated based off what
other players are doing with that
champion rather than being hand coded by
us at Riot and getting out of date and
being incorrect all that sort of thing
it will also automatically update as um
patches kind of come out update what
items are relevant for you and and make
sure that it's still a good build for
you to buy at 7 sign W ask do you think
a person's main or role is a reflection
of one's personality is there any data
or Insight available on the matter I
believe we did at one point look at uh
chat restriction and ban rights by
champion and by position and there are
some Champions out there that have
really chill player bases on average bar
players for example are generally going
to be pretty chill people without naming
any particular Champions we've got some
top laners in particular where certain
High mechanical Champions have some of
the more
vocal and likely to be penalized players
in the player base hey Andre how often
is that for yasu players they're pretty
high up there though not top of the list
but close at e jurai asks how to get
better at League of Legends after every
game you play take a moment and reflect
on what did you do poorly that game or
what could you have done better cuz
Beyond a certain point playing hundreds
or or even thousands of games won't make
you better unless you're being really
critical of your own play even in the
game where what you did fantastically
take that moment of time and reflect hey
did I did I overextend for that Ward did
I not track my mini map enough did I not
give my teammates the information they
needed those sorts of things being able
to look at your damage charts looking at
how much Vision you've you've added to
the to the game also seeing kind of like
the timeline of how each how the game
progressed and and what happened and and
your um participation in it really helps
sheare time alone doesn't matter enough
it's I think a combination of time and
critical feedback that really gets you
there definitely think learning loops
really help a lot would also encourage
if you do have a friend who can kind of
watch one of your games afterwards and
kind of talk through especially if they
have more experience what you could do
more optimally in the next uh next time
over um that's also a a great way to
kind of understand what you could be
doing better
atg asks what's the hardest role and the
easiest role to play in League of
Legends # newbie I definitely think that
jungle is pretty hard to pick up there
are so many things that you need to kind
of learn about just like map awareness
where the jungle camps are how to apply
the right amount of pressure on the
different Lanes there's just like a lot
to kind of do right so that your team is
set up to succeed but all of the roles
have their own kinds of things that you
need to learn jungle especially when
you're first starting to play the game
is probably the hardest role to learn
particularly because it's so different
than all the other roles earlier on in
the game I think support or or the bot
carry role are both fairly forgiving bot
carry can be demanding on your position
but at the very least you're playing
with an ally there somebody who will
help you out I also think mid lane can
actually be a pretty forgiving role for
a new player because the Lane's so much
shorter you're just much closer to your
Tower to a place of safety so you've got
much better odds of just being able to
run away from stuff and actually survive
it Top Lane by contrast can be pretty
merciless when you're still trying to
learn how it works what other Champions
can do to you that sort of thing I would
have said support uh maybe I would still
say support at this point just because
it kind of gives you some rhythm of
support your your ADC and and give them
the right Buffs and heels but nowadays
there's also pretty uh crazy playmaking
supports as well so there's definitely a
breath of of difficulty there too at Doo
asks how much RP do I need to be able to
use at safe log voice as announcer pack
on the rift asking for a friend okay I
kind of feel you should be the one
answering most of this question one
thing I will throw in here we are still
planning to get announcer packs as a
general feature into the League of
Legends they've been pushed back
somewhat unfortunately due to co 19 but
they're very much on a road map once
things are a bit easier to work with in
terms of exactly how much RP for a safe
blocked voice pack we're going to have
to see I I don't know what the pricing
is going to look like okay Charity
Auction maybe we'll do a charity for it
if if if everyone says they'll they'll
contribute to a charity maybe maybe I'll
record something okay hot pitch Charity
Auction where you try and fake an
announce a pack just live on stream
while somebody's playing through the
game you know what sure I'll do it I'll
do it perfect at G mous hod asks how do
you decide that a skin line is
successful and how I player can make it
return next year so we look at a few
things when we're assessing a skin line
we look at how well that skin line
performed relative to our expectations
for it how popular are the champions
that are in the skin line that sort of
thing so it's not just how many players
picked up the skin but Rel to the skin
lines expected popularity how how did it
do in addition to buying the skin we
also kind of also look at whether you
use the skin actually did you buy it but
didn't find it that interesting after a
while and so there's a different skin
that you're using the next thing we then
look at is General player excitement for
that skin line how excited are people to
have their Mains get a get a skin in
this thematic for example and then based
off a combination of those and also just
looking at how many remaining Champions
we think could be a good fit for that
skin line we figure out whether to to go
back to it or not player hunger
basically how how interested are players
in that and we'll gauge that through
things like social media discussion
through getting tweeted out directly
even sometimes if you love something
give us the feedback on it is probably
the single biggest thing in terms of
making it return next year a lot of the
time with the popular skin lines we'll
sort of have them alternate year on year
off so we might do project one year star
Guardian the next and then bounce back
to project again after that a lot of
that is just wanting to get enough
variety into the Skins we deliver we
also want to make sure that you actually
get the most out of your purchase and
actually enjoy it we just want to make
sure that whatever we make next year is
actually something you would you would
buy love and at w naramore asks are the
upcoming item changes in the preseason
going to focus more on new items
entering the game or changes to existing
items it's going to be pretty balanced
we don't want to go too far into kind of
flipping flipping the table with items
because we understand like players also
have affinity for certain items and if
anything it should just be clear about
what works for your Champion what's
purchasable and it makes sense we're
thinking about a third of the item
system should stay the same so stuff
that's already working well that'll
still be familiar another third of it
will be modified somewhat it'll be
recognizable but with a bunch of changes
and then about a third of the system
should be completely new I'd also like
to call out foris the studio behind
games like Civilization and XCOM for
that third third third system system and
we found that really helpful as a a
frame of reference when looking at
League of Legends item system Co asks
what does the honey fruit tastes like
can you eat the other plants honey fruit
is delicious it's the most amazing fruit
you've ever tasted you can also eat the
other plants blast cones are real damn
spicy so best of luck with them scries
bloom will let's just say give you some
gas but you're free to eat them at leer
peasy asks following my identity
question about League of Legends
how the hell am I supposed to know
what's my best role if I just won three
straight games as a support I picked
Leona and we stomped every single Lane
like guards I mean should I play every
lane say humble brag play Leona yes you
should play every lane at how lar asks
can you guys talk more about skins and
tease us with more Concepts please also
are we going to get star Guardian this
year I want Sona as a star Guardian so
bad she deserves that I think Sona as a
star Guardian would be super cool
definitely great that you mentioned it
so we're not going to just spoil all the
upcoming skins we've got apologies I can
tell you that we've got a handful of
completely new skin lines that we're
going to be trying over the second half
of this year and we're really excited to
get feedback from you folks on how much
you like them the best way of kind of us
getting ideas for who who could be the
next star Guardian is when when players
are asking for specific champions in
particular at storm Arthur 7 asks what
has been the biggest lesson you've
learned while working at Riot games
definitely keep learning keep adapting
from what what players are telling you
how are how they're playing the game
especially since the game itself has
changed so much over time and it's such
a deep one it's great to just kind of
get different perspectives not only from
the player base but also the people who
have come and joined Riot as players and
and want to want to just make the game
better I think good results for game
development are often much less about
that single big brain wave or whatever
that that flash of brilliance and more
about just repeatedly iterating working
as a group taking feedback getting
things wrong learning from it repeating
and eventually iterate until we get
something really good aisu asks League
of Legends question what happens if I
build full attack speed on Twisted Fate
can I just ye an entire pack of cards at
once you know what you personally can
but let's also do the math here there's
52 cards in a standard deck you can
throw out 2.5 attacks a second so the
fastest you'll get without some way
breaking the cap is throwing the whole
pack in about 21 seconds it's up to you
but 21 seconds to throw a deck of cards
doesn't feel like you're eating it to me
so I don't know maybe TF cheats and uses
magic or something but it's not looking
good at subes asks if Bard was a piece
of bread what kind of bread would he be
he'd be a souro because I love B and I
love souro and B is kind of hipster at
skyscraper zero asks do you see a
correlation between days of high heat SL
cold and than average player performance
i. do people tilt more and play worse on
days when it's super hot LOL I feel like
the only time I've ever seen this
actually manifest has been like that one
time at Staple Center where everyone was
like it it was pretty hot I I recall and
and everyone was sweating and and
everyone had to play definitely found
that probably to to be hard on the
players uh when we were when we were
watching like any normal human being you
want to be comfortable while you're
playing please don't subject yourself to
having to be an environment where you're
uncomfortable and and can't can't play
and enjoy the game but yeah as as as any
normal human I I think if if you're
trying to if you're trying to play a
sport and you're uncomfortable I'm going
to assume you're going to tilt til
pretty hard Andre what what's your
what's your followup so it's not
directly answering this question but
it's something pretty similar one thing
we did look at at one point was how much
worse players got over the course of
long gaming sessions late at night we
discovered that an awful lot of players
writers especially lose between 5 to 10%
win rate if they keep playing after
about 1 a.m. and basically when you're
still going at like 3:00 a.m. or
whatever you are losing so many more
games even if you think you're still
playing really well later on in the
evening you're probably not at kincky
decki asks are you guys planning on any
visual updates not to be confused with
fgu there's a few Champions that their
visuals didn't age well with modern LOL
over their gameplay I like Morana and
Israel visual update and I hope to see
more we call both of them vus actually
and depending on kind of the state of
the character and you know how much we
think is um iconic to that character we
decide on how much we want to preserve
and so for Morana and ezrael we did
actually change some of their gameplay
as well but because we understood that
both of those Champions have pieces of
their uh their kit that are that are
very iconic to them we wanted to make
sure that didn't feel like they were
losing out with the change when we
changed them and updated them to be more
visually impressive and upgraded and and
kind of just better versions of of their
previous selves with regards to like are
we ever going to make a visual update
again um absolutely I think that's
always going to be an option for us to
consider when we're looking at bgus and
it's just going to be a matter of kind
of where on that Spectrum we think it's
is is appropriate for that character
we've mainly been focusing on hitting
characters that need both substantial
Visual and and gameplay improvements
because the amount of work involved in
going back and updating all of a
Champions visuals is about the same if
you're keeping the old kit as if you're
getting a new kit so just get much
better value for the time span having
said that we've also got through an
awful lot of the older problematic kits
at this point I think there will come a
time where we're in a much better
position to do more updates that are
very gameplay light like more Ghana and
Israel at some point in the moderate
future and that concludes all the
questions we've got for now thanks to
all of you who submitted them we had a
lot of fun answering them and hope to do
this again someday keep playing League
see you
later